Let's take a function of x and y; f of x
is equal to x plus y-squared.
If I want to draw that, see if I can
can make a good attempt
That's my y-axis ... I'm going to draw something in perspective
this is my x-axis ... I can see the negative x- and y-axis,
I could do it in that direction ... this is my x-axis here
And if I would draw this out if y was 0, it will be
just one ... let me draw it in yellow .. it just becomes one
straight line that looks something like this.
And for every fact, we go
get a parabola in y
Y is going to look something like this
I'm just going in the positive quadrant
It will look something like this.
Actually, if you go to negative values ​​of y,
you'll see the other half of the parabola, but I'm not going
worry too much about it
So you are going to get this surface.
It looks something like this.
Maybe I'll try to draw it again
But this is our ceiling, which we will be using again.
And I'm going to get a path in the xy plane
I'm going to start at point 2 is 0. X is
equal to 2, y is 0
And I'm going to walk, just like we did in the previous video,
I'm going to walk over a circle, but this time
is the radius of the circle 2.
Go counterclockwise at that circle.
This is on the xy plane, just for it
visualize well.
So this here is a point 0, 2.
And I'm going to come back along the y-axis.
This is my path; I'm going to come back along the y axis.
and then I turn left here and then I go
here I turn left again and I come back along the x-axis
I drew it in these two shades of green.
That is my circumference.
And what I want to do: I want to calculate the area
of this small building in fact, that has a roof of
xy equals x plus y-squared. And I want
calculate the area of ​​its walls.
So you have this wall here, the base of which is the x-axis.
Then you have this wall, which lies along the curve.
It will look like some funky wall
on that crooked side there.
I'm going to do my very best to .. it will be
bend all the way up that way and then along the y-axis
It's going to have a sort of half parabolic wall right here
I am going to place the rear wall along the y-axis
I do that in orange, or no, I will use magenta
That is the rear wall, along the y-axis.
Then you have this front wall, along the x-axis.
And you have this crazy wavy curtain or wall. I will do that
maybe in blue ... that runs along this curve here,
this part of the circle with radius 2.
So hopefully you understand that visualization.
It's a little harder; I don't use any graphics
program at the moment
But I want to find the surface, the
total surface area of ​​these three walls.
And in very simple notation we can say, well, that's the surface
of those walls ... of this wall, plus that wall, plus that wall
is going to be equal to the line integral along this
curve, or along this perimeter ... whatever you want to call it
from f from xy ... so that is x plus y-squared .. ds, where ds
just a short length along our perimeter.
And since this is a closed loop, we call this
a closed line interval.
And we sometimes see this notation.
You will often come across these in physics books
And we will cover many more /
And we are going to put a circle on the interval sign
And that means no more than the outline we are working on
is a closed outline; we come back to the point where we started.
But how do we solve this now?
A good start is, just
the circumference itself.
And for convenience; we're going to divide it into three pieces.
and actually the three separate ones
calculate line integrals.
Because, you know, this isn't really a continuous outline.
So the first part ...
Let's do this first part of the curve where we
run along the circle with radius 2.
And that is pretty easy to put together if we have x. Let me ..
do each part of the outline in a different color. So if i
this part of the circumference orange color ... if we say that x equals 2 times
the cosine of t and y is equal to 2 times the sine of t and if we say that
t ... and this is only building on what we are in
saw the previous video ... when we say that t ... and that this is of t
greater than or equal to 0 and less than or equal to pi
divided by 2 ... is actually going to be the corner, that
we walk along the circle.
This will actually describe the path.
And if you know ... how I built it up a little bit
confusing, maybe good to have the parametric video
view comparisons.
So this is the first part of our path.
So if we just want to find the surface of that wall there,
we know that we have dx, dt and
dy, dt have to find
So let's do that right away.
If we say that dx, dt will be equal to minus 2 times sine t,
dy, dt is going to be 2 times cosine t, no more than
the derivatives thereof
We have seen that often enough
So if we want the surface of this orange wall, we can
taking the integral ... and if anything of this is confusing; there are
two videos for this, in which we derive this formula
... but we can get the integral of t is 0
divided up to pi by two our function of x plus y-squared and
then times the ds.
So x plus y-squared gives a height of
every block.
And then we want the width of each block,
what ds is, but we know we can rewrite ds as
the root ... creating some space there ... from dx van de
derived from x with respect to t-squared .. so that is minus 2
times sine t squared ... plus the derivative of y with
with respect to t-squared, dt.
This gives us the orange part, and then we can bow
over the other two walls.
And how can we simplify this?
Well, this is going to be equal to the integral from 0 to pi
divided by 2 of x plus y-squared
And actually, let me express everything in t.
So x is 2 times cosine t
Let me write that down.
So it is 2 times cosine t plus y, which is equal to 2 times sine t and we go
squared everything.
And then all that times this crazy radical
At the moment it looks like a difficult primitive or integral
to solve, but we will see that it is not so bad.
This will be equal to 4 times sine-square t plus
4 cosine square t.
We can divide by 4
Don't forget the DT.
This here ... let me simplify this expression
so I don't have to rewrite it all the time
This is the same as the root of 4 times
sine-squared t plus cosine-squared t.
We do know what that is: just 1.
So this whole thing just simplifies to the
root of 4, which is just 2.
So this whole thing simplifies to 2, which is nice
for solving our primitive
That makes it a lot easier
So this whole thing simplifies to ... I'm doing it on this side
I don't want to waste too much space; I still have two walls
to work out ... the integral of t equals 0 to pi divided by 2
I want to make this very clear.
I just opted for the easiest parameterization
of x and y that I could do.
But I might as well have chosen a different parameterization
but then I should have adjusted it accordingly.
So as long as you work consistently,
it should all be fine.
There is not only only 1 parameterization for this curve;
it depends on how fast you want to go
along the curve.
Watch the videos about parametric functions as you
want more depth on that.
In any case, this thing simplifies.
We have a 2 here; 2 times cosine t,
that is 4 times cosine t.
And then we have 2 times sinus t-square here.
So that is 4 times sine-square t
And then we have to multiply again with these two
so that gives us 8.
8 times sine-squared t, dt.
And then you know, sine-squared t; that seems to be
hard to find a primitive for, but we
remember that sine-squared of ... everything actually ... we can say
sine-squared u equals half of
1 min cosine 2 h.
So we can use this term again.
I can try it here; sine squared t is equal to
1/2 time 1 min cosine 2t
Let me rewrite it that way, because it will be a lot
make it easier to solve the integral.
So we get the integral from 0 to pi divided by 2 ... and actually
can I divide it, well, I'm not going to divide it ... from 4 cosinus t
plus 8 times this thing.
8 times this thing, this is the same thing as
sine squared t.
So 8 times this ... 8 times 1/2 is 4 .. 4 times 1 min cosine
2t ... just use a little trigonometry here ... and
of all that: dt.
Now, here you could easily be the primitive
must be able to find
Let's just primitivize.
The primitive of these is the primitive of cosine t
that's just sine t.
The derivative of sine is cosine.
So this becomes 4 sine t ... affecting the scalars
nothing .. and then, well let me transfer these 4.
So this is 4 times 1, which is 4; minus 4 times cosine 2t.
So the primitive of 4 is 4t ... plus 4t .. and then
the primitive of -4 cosine 2 t
Let's see, that becomes sinus 2t.
The derivative of sine 2t is: 2 times cosine 2t.
We need a minus sign here and we put a 2
there and now it should come true.
What is the derivative of -2 sine t?
Take the derivative of the inner part 2 times
minus 2 is minus 4
And the derivative of sine 2t in terms of 2t
is cosine 2t.
So there you have it; we have calculated our primitive.
Now we evaluate it from 0 to half a pi.
And what do we get?
We get 4 sine wave ... let me write this down because I don't want to
skip too much ... sine a half pi plus 4 times a half pi
that's just 2 pi minus 2 times sine wave 2 times pi divided by 2 sine wave pi
and then all that minus all this, viewed at 0
That is actually quite easy, because
sine 0 is 0
4 times 0 is 0 and sine wave 2 times 0, that is also 0.
So everything with the zeros is great.
And what do we have here?
Sine half a pi ... from the head, the sine of 90 degrees I think;
the same .. that is 1
And then the sine of pi is zero, that is 180 degrees.
So this whole piece falls away.
So we have about: 4 plus 2 pi.
So that's how we were able to surface it
calculate this first wavy wall here, and frankly
that's the hardest part.
Now let's determine the area of ​​this curve.
And you will see this other one
curves, running along the axes, many and many
be easy, but we need others
find parameterizations for this.
So let's take this curve here
make a parameterization for this
Actually, you know what?
Let me continue this in the next video, because I notice
that I go a bit over time.
I'm going to do the next two walls and then we add them all together.